Хай, пішла!
Пррр!
Ааяя!
Бррр, ааа!
Не дурій!
Йди наперед!
Йди наперед, кажу!
Пррр!
Оу!
Отак, ану чекай, баба тебе...
О, тепер в'яжемо.
О, отак!
Чекай, Гуся.
Чекай, бо баба зібралась тебе постригти.
Та чекай!
Та ти хусткою в'яжи
Я маю, оце от
Вона мені не дається.
Будемо так стригти.
І поїхали.
Зараз буде горіти.
Зараз буде горіти, буде горіти.
Ану, бабо, дай мені гралі
Ой, холодно.
Зараз буде горіти.
Запалимо оце зараз.
Запалимо.
Тут гріється молоко.
Тут ми підігріваємо молоко.
Потім виливаємо в цю бочку.
І тут, як це називається?
Телячий шлунок.
Вливаємо сюди.
Це треба помішати, накрити і дві години має стояти.
Дві - півтори.
Щоб воно перетворилося на кисляк.
На сир, а не кисляк.
То сир, то робиться таке густе, густа маса.
Потім беремо вибивачку.
Беремо це, і те що зловилось.
Це потовкли.
Треба викочувати.
Ось так.
Це потовкли.
Сир опускається на дно.
А решта підіймається догори.
Ту решту ми набираємо в відра і носимо в котел.
І там вже є мішалка, мішаємо, і варимо вурду там.
Тепер все, люди закордон їдуть.
Виїхали наші люди туди.
Там більше грошей.
А тут лишилися старі.
Край боронити.
А молоді не звикають до такої роботи.
Ніхто не хоче цього робити.
Треба любити цю роботу.
Інакше не вийде.
Дощ, холодно, шарга, ти мокрий увесь.
Треба їх гнати, щоб нічого не пропало, це велика відповідальність.
Ми для цього створені.
Може інший хтось буде бізнесом займатись.
Ми цим будемо займатись.
А хто цим буде займатись, як ми не будемо?
Все пропаде, заросте.
Бринзу ніхто не буде їсти.
Мій дідусь...
І від тата, і від мами, обидва літували полонинами,
обидва працювали по 40 років, і напевно від них це передалося по генах, що захотілося цього
Почав на полонині з 12 років літувати.
Так рік за роком.
Пас корів, потім вже ватажив два літа, варив сир.
Ну і знайшли ми тут полонину ще більшу.
Я взяв її в оренду, і почав над цим працювати.
Відновлювати, почав керувати, і все.
Так і дотепер.
Без робочого персоналу я ніхто.
І я нікуди не піду, бо треба мати з ким:
треба мати пастухів, ватага.
А хто молоді, в нас є молодший колектив, слава Богу.
Збирається вже другий рік семеро чоловік нас.
2 пастухи, ватаг, ватрак, помічник маленький 10 років, ну і я.
Тут будемо дивитися, де в нас коптиться сир.
О!
Оце який ґазда буде брати собі будза додому.
Продаємо туристам теж такі молочні сувеніри.
А решту перемолюємо і переробляємо на бринзу.
(звук трембіти)
Ви є, добре.
Змокли по дорозі?
Та так, трошки.
Корова є перша.
Чекає на вас.
Забирати можна.
Корови набираються в селі.
У різних ґаздів.
Нас вмовляли, але ми не могли більше прийняти.
Всього 100 штук - це багато.
Це багато, і це значить, що є довіра.
Люди розбирають потихеньку.
Одні йдуть, інші приходять.
Всі задоволені.
Радісні, що то зійшло з гір, там, де ми були.
Здорове, нічого не здохло, грім не вбив, ведмідь не роздер.
Питають, чи наступного року будемо йти.
Вже замовляють.
Кажуть: "ви не забудьте, ми будемо вам знову давати.
Щоб у вас лишилось місце для нас".
Бо теж все не безрозмірне.
Оця, діду, ваша?
Біла оця?
Ні.
Ну а де ваша? Оця?
Завертай.
Дуже багато людей приїжджає тепер в Карпати.
Треба вдома, в себе в країні, розвиватися.
Надавати свої послуги, виробляти свій товар.
Аби здоров'я, аби мир у державі був.
Думаю, що з часом буде все добре.